I'm back Michelle from Lab Muffin here
with more beauty and science. Today I'll
be answering some common questions on
how sunscreen and makeup work together.
Do I need to wear sunscreen every day
even though I'll be inside most of the
time? It depends. What are you trying to
achieve? If you're after skin cancer
prevention or anti-aging, wearing a daily
sunscreen can help with both. In the
biggest study on this so far, one group
of people wore sunscreen daily while the
other group only wore sunscreen when
they wanted to. After four and a half
years the skin of daily sunscreen users
had no detectable increase in aging and
were 24% less likely to show increased
signs of aging. Invasive melanomas were
almost four times less common in daily
sunscreen users. These benefits aren't
limited to places with lots of sun
either. Another study estimated that the
melanoma rate in Norway in older women
could drop by 18% with the daily use of
an SPF 15+ sunscreen. If you're
using photosensitizing ingredients in
your skincare then you'll want to use a
sunscreen because they can make your
skin more susceptible to damage by UV
light. Alpha hydroxy acids make your skin
more photosensitive. Retinoids can as
well. Yes, skincare ingredients can make
you age faster if you're not careful! If
you don't have a susceptibility to skin
cancer and you don't care about keeping
your skin looking nice then you don't
need to wear sunscreen daily. But because
you're here watching this video, then
chances are you probably should. Do I
need a separate sunscreen if my makeup
has SPF?
Yes you'll probably need a separate
sunscreen sunscreen. SPF is tested at two
milligrams per square centimeter.
SPF generally scales linearly with the
amount you apply, so applying half of
this amount will give you around half of
the labelled SPF. With most makeup
products you probably won't be applying
anywhere near two milligrams per square
centimeter. On the average face this
translates to about 1.2 grams. Here's
what 1.2 grams of powder looks like... and
this is 1.2 grams of foundation. As you can see, these amounts
are way more than most people would
normally use. So how much protection
would you get with regular use? A 10 gram
powder lasts me about nine months of
daily use so I'm using 40 milligrams at
best, which is about 30 times less than
the testing amount. This gives me an SPF
of 1.7 for an SPF 50 product and SPF of
0.5 for a product labelled SPF 15. I
personally use one pump of foundation
which is 0.2 grams. For an SPF
50 foundation that gives me SPF 8 but
for an SPF 15 foundation that gives me
SPF 2.5. The only non-sunscreen product
that most people would use enough of is
moisturizer. So you'll either need a
moisturizer or sunscreen with SPF if
your makeup quantities don't measure up.
What happens when I layer multiple
products with SPF?
Theoretically if you're applying two
milligrams per square centimetre and you
can't fit much more than that on your
face, the highest protection you can get
is the SPF of your highest product, since
any extra stuff you apply will wipe off.
But on average, people don't apply this
much. So in general,
SPF will stack if you're putting more
sunscreen ingredients on your face and
you aren't applying it perfectly. In fact,
a study found that applying two layers
of sunscreen was a good way of getting
more UV protection - 2.5 times
more. Another possibility is that
different sunscreen ingredients can
destabilize each other and break down,
which means they'll stop working.
A particularly sensitive one is avobenzone. In finished formulations the
ingredients might be protected in
certain ways, but if you're mixing them
on your skin it's very difficult to tell
if this is happening. It's a good idea to
avoid layering sunscreens containing avobenzone with products containing
octinoxate, titanium dioxide or zinc
oxide. It's safest to reapply the same
sunscreen on top or sunscreens with
similar ingredients. Can I mix sunscreen
into my makeup? This is not a good idea.
The key to a sunscreen working well is
having it form an even film on the
surface of your skin. It's incredibly
unlikely that you'll be able to mix it
evenly enough to get even coverage.
You're also changing how the sunscreen
spreads on your skin. This means you'll
end up with microscopic holes in your
coverage. Is chemical or physical
sunscreen better?
There are two broad categories of
sunscreen ingredients: organic, which is
commonly called chemical, and inorganic,
which is commonly called physical. Both
have advantages and disadvantages. I'll
be referring to them as organic and
inorganic, since there are a few newer
ingredients that are technically both
chemical and physical and it gets really
confusing. Inorganic sunscreens are zinc
oxide and titanium dioxide, organic
sunscreens are everything else. Organic
sunscreens can achieve higher UVA
protectio,n which is great for anti-aging
and fading hyperpigmentation. They also
tend to have nicer textures than
inorganic sunscreens. Inorganic
sunscreens often have a white tint that
can be annoying if you have darker skin.
However older organic ingredients that
are still quite common can cause
allergies. In the US many of the newer
chemical sunscreens aren't available at
all. I personally prefer new organic
sunscreens.
There are also sunscreens which combine
both types. Use whatever sunscreen works
best with your budget, skin type and skin
concerns. Ideally it should be higher
than SPF 15, broad-spectrum and
water-resistant. Do I need to apply
chemical and physical sunscreens
differently? Both chemical and physical
sunscreens work pretty much the same way. They form a film that absorbs UV light
and turns it into heat. A few sunscreen
ingredients like inorganic zinc oxide
and titanium dioxide and the newer
organic sunscreens Tinosorbs M & S also
reflect and scatter a small proportion
of the incoming UV light.
All of these sunscreen ingredients work
without needing to react with the skin.
This includes chemical sunscreens which
already work when they're in the tube or
applied to paper. But they do need to
form a continuous even layer between the
Sun and your skin to work well, so you
can treat them exactly the same way. This
is related to the next question...
What order should I apply my products in?
Before we start, a disclaimer. Sunscreen
is one of the best researched skincare
products, but there's very little
information on how sunscreen works with
other skincare products because it isn't
a priority in terms of money or health.
But if we keep in mind how sunscreens
work then we can make a few educated
guesses. Sunscreen needs to form an even
film on the skin and stay there to work
well. They're designed to spread and
stick to bare skin. Because of this you
should limit using products under your
sunscreen that are designed to stay on
the skin's surface. This includes makeup products like
powders, primers and foundation. Applying
moisturizer on top of your sunscreen can
decrease the protection you get. In one
study, applying moisturizer before sunscreen
didn't affect SPF but applying moisturizer
after sunscreen reduced SPF by about
one-sixth. Water-resistant sunscreens
usually form occlusive films that block
out water, so any skincare you put on
top is going to be less effective at
getting into your skin.
Lots of sunscreens contain silicones
which can help smooth out your skin
surface much like a primer, so they can
work well under makeup. So the most
practical order is skincare, sunscreen,
then makeup. This means your skincare can actually get to your skin and work, your
sunscreen is more likely to stay put, and
your makeup doesn't get messed up. How
should I apply my products so I don't
mess up my sunscreen? A very common
question is, how do I apply my other
products so I don't mess up my sunscreen
and make it ineffective?
Again the key thing to remember is that
sunscreen needs to stay in a continuous
even layer to work most effectively.
Sunscreens are generally designed to do
this automatically when applied to clean
skin and allowed to dry down. So what we
want to focus on is letting the
sunscreen form this film, then disturbing
it as little as possible. You don't want
to use anything under the sunscreen
that's designed to stay on top of the
skin since it can interfere with how
well the sunscreen film forms and how
it lasts. Both of the studies I dug up
found that moisturizers under sunscreen
didn't affect SPF. But one of them found
that water resistance decreased. The
authors suggest that it's because the
skin can't absorb as much of the sunscreen
into the dead upper layers so the
sunscreen slides around on the surface.
The oilier moisturizer had a larger
effect. So it's a good idea to avoid
using products under sunscreen that are
designed to stay on the skin's surface
like powders, primers and oily skin care
products. For products on top of
sunscreen it's a bit worse. Sunscreen
dissolves in oil and most makeup
products like liquid foundations contain
oils, so they can act like makeup
removers when you apply them on top. How
badly this messes up your sunscreen
seems to depend on a few things: the
formula of the sunscreen, the formula of
the product you're applying on top, and
how you apply it. What we know: applying
moisturizer on top of a non
water-resistant sunscreen reduced the
SPF by around 1/6. The oilier
moisturizers caused a bigger drop and
made the sunscreen slide around more.
Some sunscreens last better when rubbed
with sand than others. Sunscreens that
claimed to be rub resistant stayed on
better in one study. Waiting 8 minutes
for sunscreen to dry made it more resistant
to removal when a t-shirt was worn on
top of it. So based on this information,
my advice would be to use a sunscreen
with a higher SPF than you need. It
should be water and rub resistant if
possible. Wait 8 minutes for the
sunscreen to dry down before applying
your makeup so it's less likely to be
disturbed. Gently pat on the makeup
rather than smearing it around. You can
try using sponges or cushions to apply
foundation. They also give a nice finish
to your makeup. How can I stop my
sunscreen from balling up? If you've
tried a few sunscreens before you'll
find that some of them might ball up on
your skin when you apply them. This is
both funny looking and bad for sun
protection since rolls of sunscreen
can't protect your skin when they're no
longer on your skin. How can you reduce
the chances of this happening? Firstly
balling up can happen when your skincare
interacts with the sunscreen. Using the
sunscreen on bare skin or waiting long
enough between layers can get rid of the
issue. Using a moisturizer with SPF might
mean that you don't need skincare
underneath at all. Balling up also
happens with more friction. Patting your
sunscreen on gently can help. It can
increase the SPF you get as well - one
study found that rubbing the sunscreen
in too hard reduced SPF by 1/4. If all of
this doesn't work then it's probably
time to try to find a new sunscreen
that's more compatible with your skin.
Since my skin is naturally quite oily a
lot of sunscreens ball up on me, but I've
still managed to find a couple that
don't ball up at all. How do I look less
shiny? How can I get rid of all this oil?
Sunscreens are often quite thick and
oily to help the sunscreen ingredients
spread out and form an even film. The
problem is sometimes this can leave your
skin looking quite oily. Here's how you
can mattify it. Blotting papers: blotting
will remove some of the sunscreen and
lower protection but if you wait for the
sunscreen to dry down for around 8
minutes most of it should stay put.
Powder on top: a translucent powder on
top can soak up oil and reduce shine.
Again, try to pat this on gently. Find a
new sunscreen: sunscreen technology is
constantly improving and one of the
areas where there's a lot of attention
is on making sunscreens more
cosmetically elegant, which means more
pleasant to use. If a sunscreen isn't
working for you, try to find an
alternative.
Do I need to reapply sunscreen? How do I
reapply my sunscreen with my makeup on?
Sunscreen works less effectively as time
goes on, which is why bottles of
sunscreen always recommend reapplying
regularly. Sunscreen can be rubbed off if
you brush against it or go into the
water. The sunscreen film itself breaks
up and clumps up and gets thinner over
time because it evaporates and it
interacts with the oil and water that
your skin produces throughout the day.
This is worse if you sweat heavily. Some
older organic sunscreens aren't
photostable, which means they break down after
absorbing too much UV. Newer sunscreens
and inorganic sunscreens are photostable
which means they don't have this
specific problem, but the other two
factors mean reapplying is a good idea.
If you're reapplying sunscreen on top of
makeup, you'll either mess up your makeup
or you won't be applying enough
sunscreen to ensure complete protection.
There isn't really a way around it.
Here's what I do. If I know I'm going to
need to reapply, such as if I'm doing a
lot of outdoor activities, I keep my
makeup simple with tinted
moisturizer and cream blush, then reapply
both sunscreen and makeup every two
hours. You can also limit the damage to
your makeup by applying with a patting
motion using a cushion applicator.
Sometimes I don't even bother with
makeup. I also try to seek shade and wear
sun protective clothing where
possible. If I know I'm only going
outside for a short period, like if I'm
going on a walk after work, then I pack a
light sunscreen that works well on top
of makeup such as a powder or spray with
SPF. I also try not to stay in the sun,
and wear a hat and sunglasses. Some
people have also managed to find a
sunscreen-makeup combo that works when
you apply with a cushion, but again you
probably won't get enough for full
protection. If I know I'm only going to
get incidental sun, like if I'm heading
home after work on the train in summer,
then I don't bother reapplying and just
try not to get the window seat.
Keep in mind that the Nambour study found
all those benefits of sunscreen with an
SPF 16 product that was around in 1992.
Sunscreen SPFs have gone up a lot since
then, the formulations are far more
sophisticated and sunscreen ingredients
have improved a lot as well. So even if
you aren't keeping your sunscreen
perfect, it's probably still making a big
difference. That's all from me today! Send
me all your questions, if you like this
video please subscribe, and check out my
blog for more beauty science :)